men lie less than women
except when they talk about their
feelings
the greatest problem in the world today
is intolerance
everyone is so intolerant of each other
carry out a random act of kindness with
no expectation of reward
safe in the knowledge that one day
someone might do the same for you
where there is a marriage without love
there will be love without marriage
only do what your heart tells you
being a princess
isn't all that it's cracked up to be
every one of us needs to show how much
we care for each other
and in the process
care for ourselves
you can't comfort the afflicted
without afflicting the comfortable
nothing brings me more happiness
than trying to help the most vulnerable
people in society
it is a good and essential part of my
life a kind of destiny
a mother's arms are more comforting than
anyone else's
to cheat on a loved one
means to cheat on oneself
people think that at the end of the day
a man is the only answer
actually
a fulfilling job is better for me
if you find someone you love in your
life
then hang on to them
[Music]
if men had to have babies
they would only ever have one each
if you find someone you love in your
life
then grab to that love
you cannot replace a slender figure with
any beautiful necklace
long legs are always more attractive
than an expensive dress
i conjure all the men of the world
if you want to be loved and respected by
your wives
do not forget that their main protectors
are you
when you are happy
you can forgive a lot
a woman confesses to treason when she
loves because she wants to be honest
and a man will never forgive
because he also loves
experience is invaluable not only
because thanks to it we learn something
new
but also because it makes us reconsider
our past
when someone cheats on you
it is better to be in the dark
but if the blindfold is already torn off
your eyes
it is preferable to see clearly
than unclear
the philosophical mindset
is the art of enduring the misfortunes
of others
before proposing
make sure that your chosen one doesn't
have rainbow glasses on and that she
sees everything in its true light
otherwise the most sincere love can
bring trouble
the thing women like the most in bed
is breakfast
a bullet can whistle past
and treason is always right in the heart
[Music]
you